back tis the season for shopping and as
you start making your list of gifts for
the holidays and everyone on your list
Downtown Summerlin has you covered
joining us with the holiday gift guide
from downtown Summerlin we have our
friend Haley harzinski who I am just
loving the jacket Sparkle you look so
festive thank you well Downtown
Summerlin has kind of become my home
away from home we did some fun holiday
stuff out there last week but now we're
talking about gifts you guys have so
many different options for anyone and
everyone on your list so let's talk
about it what are some ideas for this
year absolutely so our newest retailer
is Kendra Scott and she you know we
really love this retailer they have a
fun color bar that you can customize
jewelry they have a bunch of necklaces
that are you can layer and I really
think it's just a really great gift for
your mom or your daughter and they just
have a variety of everything and what's
really great is they actually carry the
men's collection at our Downtown
Summerlin location so you can kind of
shop for your husband or you know your
son as well and kind of hit two birds
with one stone I didn't even know there
was a men's collection that is awesome
that you have that at the downtown
Summerlin location I gotta come check
get out and get something for everyone
in my family okay I see a candle I love
big candle I know this is amazing and so
this is all from Nordstrom Rack and the
great thing about Nordstrom Rack is you
kind of get a bit of a deal but yeah
it's all still really great so this is a
nest candle and if you're familiar with
nest candles they're luxury candles and
you can kind of save a few bucks and
then you also have great stocking
stuffers if you go to the checkout line
there's so many tubs of things you can
get sugar Spina candy those are great to
just throw into the stocking and these
like cute little hair ties from slip
which don't increase your hair and
things like that so they just have all
the stocking stuffers that you need as
well I'm guilty of picking those little
things when you wait in line that's how
they get you yeah we have a lot of great
options there okay we're moving on to
anthropology anthropology is just great
all year round for holiday gifts and so
this year they have an entire collection
of you know glassware which these little
fun champagne glasses or if you can do
shaking cocktails in there a fun holiday
cocktail book this has over 50 recipes
and again just really cute stocking
stuffers this uh soap bar of soap is a
winter event but it comes with these
little cute sleighs at the bottom and so
it's just really personalized and it's
exclusive to anthropology and it just
makes it fun the bath bomb in the little
gingerbread house really fun and just
great for kids of all ages as well as
your best friend your co-worker just
great the problem with holiday shopping
is you go shopping for other people and
you end up buying yourself something so
I know I would buy myself that soap
that's really cute speaking of soaps and
lotions and hands I love this store tell
me about it with love is amazing and if
you can't shop this week go there on
shop small business Saturday she makes
everything handmade locally organic and
so anything from lotions to face scrubs
and it's really great you can spend all
day and they're just testing everything
I know it smells so good like you could
eat it I have a bunch of the hand
lotions okay and I love shoes but talk
about this and where these are from Nike
Red Rock is one of our newest tenants as
well and what's so great about Nikes
they have so many styles for both men's
women's kids babies and so you can kind
of like buy kicks for the whole family
that'll match and so I thought you know
a little his and her Air Force Ones for
the Christmas mess was just so fun and
so you can go in they also offer these
really cute mini sneaker boxes for when
you buy gift cards so it just adds a
little nice touch as well so but Nike
Red Rock is just always always a great
go-to I love anything mini in it we have
to wrap up but I know you guys have a
2023 calendar with all the doggies on it
so be sure to pick up one of these uh
you can't go wrong a perfect stocking
stuffer Haley thank you so much for
being here breaking it all down go get
all your holiday shopping done at
downtown Summerlin JC I'll send it